president biden desperately trying to
sell his massive spending agenda while
voters panic about inflation the cargo
ship crisis getting worse even after
biden promised to fix it gas prices are
surging and store shelves are empty the
white house says everything is fine but
americans are taking notice nine out of
ten voters are worried about rising
prices of goods ranking yet the top
issue among people who are extremely
concerned about it instead of trying to
fix the problems all biden can do is
push the same talking points about his
spending plan
the cost of the bill back better bill in
terms of adding to the deficit is zero
zero
zero and it does
not increase the debt when you talk
about the number we shouldn't even talk
about the numbers because it's all paid
for in addition to that half of it is a
tax cut
it's not spending money it's a tax cut
for working class people
dana when a politician repeats the same
word over and over again i think he's
probably lying uh
i don't know a lot of politicians do
that uh exactly and they're all lines
biden has lost 11 points in a month
among democrats on his handling of the
account so um one of their biggest
problems is that
president biden is pushing a five
trillion dollar bill that doesn't
address the pain that anybody's feeling
so naturally you have polling armageddon
senator schumer's own pac
showed that in the last five months
president biden with persuadable voters
went from a plus five to a negative 30.
so
it's not going in the right direction
for the democrats and at the same time
you have the white house trying to woo
senator manchin and they're trying to
isolate kirsten cinema what i've seen
from kirsten cinema is that she's got
somebody that you want to dare
because she is not going to be pushed
around she doesn't care about that
there's two big things for them senator
manchin says he doesn't like the short
sunsets this is the gimmick where they
pass all the freebies but they only pay
for it for a year
and then in the election of 2022 they'll
ask all the republicans how dare you not
be for children etc but the other thing
is
kirsten cinema has said she doesn't want
any new taxes so now their whole idea
that as you just saw the president say
it costs nothing it costs zero i don't
see how they make that math work and
that's in opposition to even uh joe
manchin's small plan but greg it's the
lying in response you know the tragedy
of the treadmill yes
this is about the supply chain chaos
right now where are the emergency orders
right to free up money for truck driver
schools where are they to temporarily
lift bans on freelance trucking or
suspend regulations you know joe's
previous
emergency orders weren't this urgent and
some of them you might say were symbolic
i can't remember which ones but i
remember pipeline yes exactly so that's
a problem there's nobody in charge uh
say what you will about trump he
probably would have crushed this uh he
would have dealt this the way he dealt
with the vaccine he would have warped
speed for truckers the second day that
he heard about it he'd get 80 000 new
truckers he would have definitely fired
mayor pete it would have been hilarious
it'd be like two months
crisis it's two months what are you
doing you're like and then that he would
be gone but instead all we get is we get
joe biden like talking like a 10 year
old trying to explain to his parents a
dream that he had you know there was
this train
and then a bird came it's like it's it
it's incredible i because it's halloween
i came up with an analogy
uh the white house is coming to
halloween as the headless horseman
because
this administration has no head there's
no leadership there's no face of this
administration it's not gen saki it's a
decapitated vessel on a tricycle is what
we got right now and uh that's why
that's why there are no ideas and only
spending
because there's no head
and they've disemboweled the economy oh
nice foreign
powerless i don't know what's worse
they the economy the economy is expected
to grow half of one percent right now it
was expected to grow two months ago at
six percent and it's all of the
inflation in the supply chain problems
all biden
the s p 500 closed at a record today so
there is i think a disconnect between
everyday middle-class americans working
americans and perhaps the old the ultra
wealthy and those who are invested
not but those who are invested in the
ultra wealthy i think what joe biden is
trying to do is to address some of those
things and i'm i'm not one to think that
you should over tax anyone i'm not one
of the things you should over regulate
anyone but i am one that thinks that
we've got to lay out what our priorities
are and i would agree with agree with
greg as you saw yesterday i thought the
president missed an opportunity early in
the speech that's why i wanted to go
back to the speeches i thought maybe
later in the speech we would have
articulated more clearly but he got
going and it took him a while to get
going but you've got to lay out why are
we spending this money is it too much is
it too little and at this point i would
agree we're not there yet the narrative
is not as tight as it should be but
they're going to get a deal mansion is
going to get a deal with sanders and if
sanders and the progressives don't want
to play with mansion then we may not get
anything at all and that would be a real
disaster for my party
i just want to point out that the wealth
gap narrowed under president trump and
it's being blown apart under biden
because the rich are getting richer
because of the federal reserve the fed
what the federal reserve is doing is
making the rich it's inflating assets
but the biden administration needs the
fed to monetize the debt to stop up all
the debt that they're issuing
to fund the spending i digress you want
to go fox business on us all of a sudden
all right this is what i'd say about
that working classes are getting screwed
no i would i would agree
the fed is going to have to raise rates
to tame inflation right eventually
you're going to have to suck it up and
do that no matter what political cost
that is going to be to joe biden so
they're going to have to raise them it's
going to make the market correct itself
and then what do we have we might be
looking at stagflation slow growth high
inflation higher rates jimmy carter 2.0
also the sound bite from joe biden did
he just call the most expensive bill in
american history a tax cut that costs
nothing yes
that tells me he can't sell this thing
so he's now using republican talking
points to try to sell this thing greg
made a great point we know politicians
can't move heaven and earth but at least
act like you're trying to do something
declare an emergency act like you're
doing something with the poor tape maybe
all the unvaxxed people that you fired
through your mandate make them be truck
drivers you don't have to interact with
anybody as a truck driver you stay in
the truck unvaxxed
ride it out i mean at least i came up
with an idea he has no idea to solve the
number one problem facing this country
he just says it's a good thing suck it
up peasant
yes you had a great idea about hygiene
this is another great idea i'm going to
write this one
what was my hygiene
yeah we talked about how you light a
candle to get the smell out of there
that was a short cut oh okay
i gave you credit i gave you credit
thank you
yeah and you don't spend trillions to
bring down inflation
up next a disturbing trend another
example of people recording crimes
instead of calling the cops